well it's my birthday today and all I
want for my birthday is for everyone to
help vocab get a new laptop because his
laptop is like six or seven years old
and it keeps breaking and he keeps
wasting money fixing an old laptop that
Now sucks vocab normally deals with
heretical groups like the Hebrew
Israelites but you've seen him in some
of my greatest video series like
Muhammad's Boom Boom Room and islamicize
me where he ends up getting multiple
death sentences for being in whatever
insane videos I come up with there would
be no Boom Boom Room without vocab so
it's always good to help a guy who's
putting his life on the line now if
you've been supporting my work for a
while you actually bought the laptop he
has now in fact if you've been
supporting my channel for a while a lot
of apologists have equipment that you
paid for but now we're cutting out the
middleman because Nate set up a GoFundMe
for vocabs laptop Nate set the goal at
2500 I'm telling you from experience
that's too low you can get an awesome
laptop for 2500 but if you're editing 4K
video footage and you're running five or
six programs during your live streams
you generally want the best processor
and memory you can get the good laptops
for what we do run between 5, 7500
that's a lot but if we all chip in five
or 10 or 20 bucks we can get that
covered in no time so click the link in
the description box so we can get vocab
a new laptop and this will be the best
birthday
ever